guys team wolf the TV series came about
after the movie Teen Wolf with Michael J
Fox I was just wondering if you'd had a
thought about making a Teen Wolf movie
yourself and what that might be
well Tyler Posey and I always talked
about what we'll do for the movie I
personally like to do a movie just to
have the time in preparation I could
spend months writing one script instead
of three days writing one script and we
would have prepped for fight scenes and
we'd have a bigger budget it would be
really fun if the fifth season is
potentially the last season of Teen Wolf
then I'd love for there to be a movie
afterwards what do you guys think go for
a movie dude that'd be awesome you're up
for movie pay yeah we work hard I think
a movie would be nice that's between you
and your your agents in the network and
then that work guess what would you guys
like staking your character
Cemal for movies lots of action and
drama and heartbreak yeah I think also
just depends on what happens is next
season too because um yeah I have no
idea mean if you survive if I know
that's a good boy okay kill know if
we're bad they kill us so yeah that's a
great thing about doing a genre show if
the actors are bad you can just kill
them is that what happened to Scott's
first love interest no no no we actually
I miss crystal and I miss crystal Tom we
text here and there and um that was
actually a I'm sort of shocking it
shocked me actually I can't watch it
anymore I get to her it's it's first of
all it's kind of violent so it's sort of
stunning for me to see one of my own
characters be impaled on screen I
remember seeing the daily and I was like
wow did we really do that but I thought
it was good for the show of it in in the
end of things uh it shook things up the
show needed a kind of reboot I think
especially after a certain number of
episodes we've done 60 episodes now
we've got 20 more it's kind of it's
shocking to me that it's surprising I
should say
that Teen Wolf is gone 80 episodes and
now when I am I talked to fans they come
up to me some fans come to me and says
how did you come up with the idea for
Teen Wolf I'm like well I didn't it was
a movie do you remember the Michael J
Fox movie and people look at me as ik no
they're too young I guess so
yeah you brought up Michael J Fox then
um has there been any discussion about
having him come on
for camiolo we get a lot of this
question a lot um I would love that
uh I know he knows of the show but I
don't he's seen it has he said anything
has he contacted the show at all now we
should get in touch with him shouldn't
we
but there was a certain point with the
network where they wanted to completely
distance themselves from the original
movie but um is that because you're so
vastly different and yeah yeah I think
we wanted to get away from it I mean in
in Hollywood these days it's all about
branding and very little is made without
a previous brand the spec market for
movies has been completely destroyed
they're only interested in making toys
and and games into movies or books that
are known properties so for me when they
asked me to do Teen Wolf I said okay
it's a brand it has that much more
potential to be made as a TV series but
it was really just a jumping-off point
we very very much have we there's very
little left of the movie in this TV
series which is fine because who knew
that 60 episodes would be made out of
Michael J Fox basketball comedy starring
awareness what can you guys see the
season five and how many oh you can
think okay um uh I can tease very little
of season five other than well we've
only done about a week or so in the
writers room just brainstorming ideas
we're really happy to have time now -
we've got our longest break in two and a
half years we it was actually sort of
kind of a marathon the last two years
because if we put
and we aired in 14 months 36 episodes
which is very hard to do for a show like
ours so we now have a good bit of
preparation so we're really think
keeping things open but we we can say
that it's senior year it's going to be
20 episodes instead of the 12 episodes
story arc we're going to do a full story
arc through the 20 episodes with
probably a big cliffhanger in the middle
if there's a season 6 that would be
great
but that's sort of up in the air we'll
see it's not my decision it's networks
but it'd be amazing
you